all right so you are ready to transition  from your normal typical it roll to a  cloud rule great you can exploit your  unfair Advantage which is you already  know a lot of the stuff that is  translatable to Cloud cloudify your  skills let's say you're a DBA  deploy a database in Cloud using a  virtual machine then transition that to  automating that process of deployment  and then third step start using a  database that is already Cloud native or  or comes in in cloud services like maybe  Cloud SQL or spanner then step two would  be boosting your targeted skills coding  Linux OS fundamentals of containers  networking these are super important if  you haven't brushed up on them do so now  then consider a stepping stone roll that  might be it there might be time when you  need to take a stepping stone sort of  role like help desk to transition into  that ideal role that you're looking for